At the beginning of the movie, Nurse Marion, the
same nurse from the original Halloween, sends her teenage
neighbor Jimmy to investigate a break-in at
her house. He proceeds to raid her fridge,
where we can see a six-pack of Penn Pavel’s beer
on the shelf. This fictional beer company can
be spotted in many films and TV shows; The Truman
Show, Donnie Darko and The Walking Dead, are a few
examples. But what is the reason for this? What is
the connection between these seemingly random IPs?
It goes back to the specialty
print shop, The Earl Hays Press,
who produced this beverage prop as a neutral
brand for several different productions.
The Earl Hays Press is most known for creating
fake news articles for Hollywood. We see a
lot of this during the opening titles
for Halloween H20: 20 Years Later, or,
as I’ll be referring to it for the rest of
this video for my time and your sanity, H2O.
I know this breaks my usual schtick of exact
pronunciations, but I’m gonna call it H2O because
that’s how my brain interprets it. These articles
contain some interesting details… to learn
about that, plus all the ways that this movie
interacted with the Scream franchise, who this
lady really is, plus many other easter eggs and
secrets, stick around to the end of this video.
Sponsored by Ridge Wallet.
The slim modern wallet that holds up to 12 cards plus cash
in over 30 colors including carbon fiber and burnt titanium.
It's durable and comes with a lifetime warranty, plus
ever dollar you spend on Ridge Wallet before September 30th
enters you to win a brand new upgraded Ford Bronco.
Check out the link in the description and use code CZSWORLD for 10% off.
(metal music)
Welcome to another episode of Things
You Missed. My name is Zac, aka CZ,
and I am analyzing the entire Halloween
franchise here on this channel. There
are many different routes you can travel on the
Halloween Express. Currently, after Halloween 2,
you can choose to continue on to Halloween
4-6, or you can opt for a different reality,
where nothing happens for the next 20
years until Halloween H20. In this episode,
no surprises, I’ll once again be aided
by Halloween expert Jimmy Champane.
– [Jimmy] Directed by Steve Miner, this film
represents a semi-rebirth of the franchise.
It was the first Halloween movie to be released
in Summer, it takes place in a
fictional town called Summer Glen, the first
return to the Golden State since Halloween III.
The title, H-twenty resembles H2O, the chemical
compound name for water. Despite that,
there’s no pools, no beaches and we don’teven
get to see Michael Myers cutting up any girls in
bikinis. Instead, it takes place in a boarding
school where Laurie Strode lives a secret life
as a headmistress under a false name. This is
now the third alias she’s used: Laurie Strode,
Laurie Myers, and now Keri Tate, all to evade her
murderous brother, whose name precedes him. So go
ahead and grab some sunscreen and a towel,
and let’s dive into the Things You Missed.
(knives slash)
(50s music)
– [Zac]The opening song is Mr. Sandman by the Chordettes,
the same song used in Halloween 2, where it tied
into themes about dreams and the unconscious
mind. In this case, it’s more of a callback,
and maybe a slight reminder that Halloween 2
is still canon, while 4-6 are not. We actually
hear the song again later, in Laurie’s car,
and we see her react to it and turn it off.
It’s almost like she’s reacting to her painful
memories of Halloween 2, which wouldn’t make any sense
because the song was never used diegetically,
meaning that we the audience could hear it,
but the characters did not. So, I don’t know,
maybe Laurie is just not a Chordettes fan.
The part where Laurie gets startled by the
little girl in the clown costume is much
more understandable, because it’s well known that
Michael wore a clown costume for his first attack.
Back to the opening, we see that
Nurse Marion is still a smoker, and she
too has taken on a new last name: Whittington.
It’s not clear if this is also for protection,
or if she just married at some point.
After realizing her home has been INVADED,
she goes to the neighbors for help, and
they have a Halloween decoration of one
of the cenobites from the Hellraiser
franchise. It’s Butterball, the one
that looks like the gritty live action
version of Patrick Star from SpongeBob,
if he were in a Matrix movie. Hellraiser,
from the third movie onward, was produced or
distributed by Dimension Films, who also did the
90s and 2000s Halloween films -- you may remember
the Pinhead pumpkin I pointed out in the last
movie, Halloween: The Curse of Michael Myers.
– [Jimmy] Dude, if they ever remake this movie, instead
of Butterball they should definitely use Harvey Weinstein.
– [Zac] There’s another horror icon referenced
moments later when we see this kid dressed up
as Jason from Friday the 13th. H20 director
Steve Miner also did the second and third
Friday the 13th films. Also, the Detective
in H20 is named Fitzsimmons,
the same name as the police chief
from Friday the 13th Part III.
The address of Marion’s house is also a
reference to one of Steve Miner’s films.
– Yeah, yeah. It’s 4946 Cypress Pond.
– [Zac] The 4946 comes from the real location where
this scene was shot, 4946 Melrose Hill Street,
and Cypress Pond is an address
referenced in Steve Miner’s 1992
film Forever Young, which
also stars Jamie Lee Curtis
– Susan Finley's address is 14 Cypress Pond Road.
– Miner also has an uncredited cameo as
this very apologetic school official
who tells Molly about her financial aid situation.
– [Miner] He said he wasn’t going to be there.
I’m very sorry, I wish I could help.
– [Molly] But he promised that--
– [Miner] No.
– Brutal. One of the teens that helps
Marion is wearing a hockey jersey
with an L and the number 17 on it. The
name Laurie starts with an L and she was
17 during the original Halloween. Not sure
if that is what they were going for there.
– [Jimmy] Either way, he’s about to take a big L
from our boy Michael Myers. His name is Allegre,
a French word meaning happy, joyful or cheerful.
All of which he is... until he dies.
It turns out Michael ransacked Marion’s office,
there are papers everywhere and the file on Laurie
Strode has been emptied. This scene is the
parallel to Halloween 4, when
Michael goes through Jamie’s photo box and finds
out that she’s related to Laurie Strode. Marion tries
to turn on the lights, but realizes that the power has been
cut; which is another thing that Michael does in Halloween 4.
Marion also has a picture of Loomis. When
we see him, the music resembles music from
the original film. The picture is also
an homage to Donald Pleasence,
who unfortunately died shortly after makingHalloween 6:
The Curse of Michael Myers.
One by one, Michael takes out everyone
involved, starting with the teenage neighbors.
One of them gets a skate through the head
while watching Plan 9 From Outer Space, which
seems to be an intentional callback to The original Halloween when Laurie and Tommy are watching The Thing
From Another World.
Both of these movies are sci-fi films from the 50s.
– [Zac] There’s also this license plate:
ITA1959. The same year Plan 9 From Outer Space
came out. Coincidence? I think, probably.
And once again, Michael’s attack on Nurse Marion
results in him stealing a car.
Grand Theft Auto: Haddonfield.
During the opening credits, we see Marion’s
collection of Michael Myers memorabilia,
which she inherited from Dr. Loomis. We see
articles from after his initial attack on his
older sister in ‘63, and this one, dated the
day after the main events of Halloween (1978),
before it goes into speculations
about if Michael is still alive.
There are photos of people we’ve never seen
before, which seems to suggest that Loomis
or Marion suspected Michael of having
other victims during the 20 year gap.
There are a couple mistakes in these
articles, like the one that says “Laurie
Strode sole survivor of October Mass
Murders”. This forgets about Loomis,
Tommy, Lindsey and Jimmy, all of whom survive.
– [Jimmy] Not me Jimmy. The movie Jimmy. But not the
H2O Jimmy. The old Jimmy. Too many Jimmys.
– [Zac] This article incorrectly states
that the Halloween murders occured in 1968,
it was actually ‘78. Then there’s this
one. “Authorities have no explanation for
the disappearance of the headstone of Judith
Myers from Memorial Cemetery.” No explanation,
huh? You don’t think maybe it was… I don’t know,
Judith’s brother? The same guy responsible for
killing all those teenagers, one of whom
was arranged under that very tombstone
at the crime scene that same day? Not the most
excellent deductive skills from Haddonfield PD.
I went through the movie shot by shot to see
what additional lore these articles contain.
What I found was the truth behind how
Michael escaped all of those years ago,
but also, a lot of other weird stuff.
(impact)
If you watch Things You Missed regularly,
there are a lot of details in newspapers
that come up on this show. Oftentimes,
we see a headline, but the content of
the article is totally unrelated, because
when you’re watching the movie in real time,
you don’t have time to read the whole
article. This one, from November 1963,
starts as a legit story about Michael
Myers, then changes topics mid-sentence.
“He is currently undergoing
tests for a number of disorders. The
boy has no history of violence. With
the advent of modern medical imaging,
third term fetuses have been observed
doing complicated dance movements.”
I sometimes find it frustrating
when the filmmakers can’t be bothered to
just write a fake in-universe article, but
in this case, he was so close to filling the
required space that the article takes
up, that it’s making me think the prop
designers actually do this weird stuff on
purpose, as an inside joke or trivia item.
This other article tells the story of how Michael
actually escaped the sanitarium all those years
ago, by climbing out a second story window and
descending on a handmade rope consisting of
stolen bedsheets, like something out of a cartoon.
I don’t really know what the point of all that is,
considering that Michael is invincible and can
pretty quickly recover from any fall damage,
as we see again towards the end
of H20, when Laurie knocks him
off of a balcony as a callback to the
original, and he survives both times.
– [Jimmy] They didn’t even have to come up with
something new to explain how he escaped.
It’s spelled out in the first movie
when Marion and Loomis show up.
Michael lets the inmates out and escapes in the
chaos. We literally see them walking around!
– [Zac] Now that you mention it, yeah, you’re
100% right. Once again, this article is 90%
legit, until they randomly start talking about
Michael doing these “complicated dance movements”.
I guess they call him the boogeyman because he
knows how to boogie. At least they know how to
spell his name correctly though, unlike this
article which spells it like the soap brand.
Just when I thought I’d finally found a
decent article about death row inmates,
the story randomly starts talking
about “third term fetuses doing
complicated dance movements”. It’s
gotta be some kind of inside joke.
– [Jimmy] One interesting detail in terms of lore
is the article that states Laurie died in an auto
accident. Not only is this how Laurie’s parents
died, but it’s also how she died over in the
Halloween 4-6 timeline. This leads me to believe
that this is a holdover from an earlier revision
of Halloween H20 script. The movie was originally
planned to be a sequel to Halloween 6
before the idea of a new timeline was decided on. If you're looking really close
you can see the stained
scissors Halloween 4,
but, obviously, that movie didn't happen in this timeline, so we're just going to go ahead and assume that they were a pairof scissors used
in the 20 year gap
where Loomis was hunting down Michael.
Or it could be an intentional easter egg to Halloween 4.
I just don't want to give them that much credit.
– [Zac] After the opening credits, we see
a long POV shot, a callback to the way the
original Halloween began. You can also see white
sheets blowing in the breeze. White sheets were
a psychosexual motif that I talked about in the
original Halloween, I’ve pointed out how they come
back in nearly every Halloween movie since. This
all turns out to be part of Laurie’s nightmare,
and it does a nice job of setting up the horror
well before she sees this hauntingly familiar
image when Michael is actually coming
after them towards the end of the movie.
Laurie is now an English teacher, which is
fitting after we saw her excel in her high
school English class back in the original.
There’s a reimagining of that scene,
where her son’s girlfriend Molly is sitting in the
back corner and she sees Michael out the window,
the same thing that happened to Laurie when
she sat in that spot two decades prior. When
Laurie calls on Molly to answer her question
about Frankenstein, Molly talks about how
Victor Frankenstein should have confronted his
monster sooner to prevent Elizabeth’s death.
– I mean, the monster saw to that
by killing off everybody that he
loved. Victor finally had to face it. It
was about redemption. It was his fate.
– [Jimmy] If you recall, during that Halloween
afternoon in 1978, Laurie’s curriculum also talked
about the idea of “fate” in the class that she's in. In the
original, fate is described as an immovable force.
In other words, Michael was an immovable force of nature
that would come for Laurie, and there was nothingat all
she could do to stop it. All she could do was run
and hide. But in H20, fate is still portrayed as
an inevitable confrontation, but Molly suggests
that the character, Victor Frankenstein, has to
face his fate in order to redeem himself, which is
exactly what we see Laurie do at the most critical
point in the story. This version of Laurie has
been running and hiding every step of the way.
Even when she has to confront Michael in the first movie,
it's usually done in self-defense.
– [Zac] There’s even a banner in her
classroom that says Learn from the Past,
Live in the Present, Plan for the Future, but
she doesn’t follow that advice herself. It’s very
clear that she’s stuck in the past. She spends
her whole life in fear of her brother’s return,
and there comes a point where she has the kids
in the car with an opportunity to run away once
again. But she remembers her own teachings
in the English class, and instead of fleeing,
she goes back to kill her monster. This character
arc is three movies in the making for her.
But before we get there, let’s talk about
life at Hillcrest Academy. Actually,
with that fancy font, it almost looks more
like Killcrest Academy. Where do I enroll?
– So are you studying to
be a killer? Or a final boy?
– No comment. Laurie is very
overprotective of her teenage son,
and as a side effect, kind of prevents
him from living his life. As this unfolds,
we see her grab the box of Life cereal,
and put it away for safekeeping. This
feels somehow symbolic. Even John’s
friends make fun of him for it.
– Twenty years from now you’re
still gonna be living with her.
Probably running some weird motel
out in the middle of nowhere.
– Yep, it wouldn’t be a Things You Missed
episode if there wasn’t some kind of
reference to Hitchcock’s 1960 horror classic,
Psycho. If you somehow haven’t seen it,
it’s about a character named Norman Bates,
who at one point lives with his mother,
Norma Bates and they run the appropriately
titled family business: The Bates Motel.
Jamie Lee Curtis, who plays Laurie,
is the daughter of Janet Leigh,
who stars in Psycho, and she also makes
a cameo in H20, where her name is Norma.
– [Norma] Oh good morning Ms. Tate.
– Good morning, Norma.
Norma is the one to deliver this line…
– Well, it's Halloween. I guess
everyone is entitled to one good scare.
– [Zac] …which is the same iconic line that
Sheriff Brackett has in the original,
and later on in Halloween
Kills. During that conversation,
Norma senses Laurie’s distress
and offers some maternal advice.
– I know it’s not my place … If
I could be maternal for a moment…
…Which is funny, because, again, that
is her actual mother in real life.
– It’s all so corny. It kills me every time I see it.
– As she walks away, we hear
a little piece of Bernard Hermann’s
musical score from Psycho and she returns
to her vehicle, which is just like the one
her character drives in Psycho. It even
has the same license plate number. That
was probably enough of a Psycho homage,
but hey, why not add one more in there?
– Psycho.
– I also noticed some music by
H20’s composer John Ottman,
that isn’t from Psycho, but is very
reminiscent of Bernard Hermann’s style.
(eerie music)
– Unfortunately for Ottman, some of his music was taken out and literally just straight up replaced with
music from Scream. The scene where
Michael chases them through the corridors uses the
music from the garage scene in Scream, and part
of the intro with Nurse Marion uses music from the
Casey Becker intro in Scream. In fact, you probably
realized that H20’s intro itself is very
similar to the intro from Scream. Both involve a woman home
alone and realizes she’s being stalked at the
front and back door, who then contacts the police, but
before they arrive, runs outside to try to escape.
– In fact, there are many elements of H20
that just scream Scream, from the contemporary
media references to the Northern California
setting. And there are two reasons for this.
One. Scream came out in 1996 and revitalized
the slasher genre in a way that 1995’s Curse
of Michael Myers did not. Kevin
Williamson was heavily involved in writing the
script, despite not getting the final on screen
credit. Two. The original Halloween was heavily
featured in Scream as the movie that the kids
all watch at Stu Macher’s party. The Halloween
franchise would link back to Scream by showing
Scream 2 as the movie that Molly and Sarah have on
TV in their dorm room. Scream 2 is also the Scream
movie that takes place on campus, much like H20.
If you’ve seen my Scream Things You
Missed, you know all about how the
intro of Scream has a part where Mr.
Becker discovers their home has been
broken into and tells his wife to go down to
the Mackenzie’s house and call the police.
– Get in the car. Drive down to
the MacKenzies’. Call the police.
– This was a reference to the original Halloween,
where Laurie tells Tommy and Lindsey to go call
the police from the Mackenzies’, so in
H20, the Halloween franchise responds,
by having Laurie tell the kids to
call the police from the Beckers’.
– I want you to drive down the street
to the Beckers’, a mile down the road.
Tell them to call an ambulance and get the police.
– [Zac] There was even a connection between
Ghostface and Michael Myers. H20 Michael
was played by Chris Durand, who was under
the Ghostface mask for parts of Scream 2.
As much as I could go on about the newfound
relationship between Halloween and Scream,
we haven’t even begun to talk about who Laurie
was talking to on the phone, connections to the
original movie that you might have overlooked,
and the rest of the Things You Missed.
(impact)
(mysterious music)
The group of students staying back from
Hillcrest Academy’s Yosemite field trip
consists of two couples. In the original
Halloween, there were also two teen couples:
Annie and Paul being the first; Lynda and Bob
being the second. Like the teens from Halloween,
these kids only have one thing on their minds.
– Food. *wink*
– [Charlie] Whole place will be empty. We could have the run
of it. We could have a roaming orgy!
– [Sarah] I like the way this man thinks!
– Unlike last time however,
this time Laurie is also getting in
on the romantic activities. She’s
dating the guidance counselor,
Mr. Brennan, who brings a pumpkin over
to her dwelling on Halloween night.
– I thought we’d do this right.
History is kind of repeating itself here. In
1978, Laurie brought a pumpkin along to her
babysitting job to carve with Tommy. There are
a number of small moments like this that serve
as homages to Halloween. For example, after
hanging Sarah, Michael does the same head
tilt thing that he did after killing Bob Simms in
the original. Almost as if he’s admiring his work.
Actually, the very idea of hanging Sarah
from above, like a Halloween decoration,
calls back to what Michael later did with
Bob, where he was strung up in a closet.
The moment where Laurie and Michael come
face-to-face in the window harkens back
to the brief eye contact they made twenty years
prior when Laurie pulled off her brother’s mask.
Not long after, she hides the kids in a
closet, the same strat she used to hide
Tommy and Lindsey all those years
ago. She even uses the same line.
– Do as I say, now!
– Mr. Brennan’s death involves him being stabbed
and lifted off the ground with the knife,
the same fate that we saw befall the nurse from
Halloween 2. And temporarily knocking out Michael,
Laurie makes the same mistake she made in the
original by dropping the knife. At the end,
we see Michael get brake-yeeted out the
front windshield, as he was in Halloween 4.
Before the rampage, Mr. Brennan goes
to check on all the students remaining
on the campus. But did anyone else
find his word choice kind of ominous?
– [Mr. Brennan] Sarah. Molly. Just
checking on the Hillcrest remains.
– A little strange, considering one of them
would soon become a pile of human remains.
And then when John makes the little map for
Molly and sends it down the dumbwaiter… it
looks innocent enough… but what’s this?
I recognize this from our Purge videos,
that’s an Iron Cross. John Tate is Nazi confirmed.
Also, I think I found where they
got the title of this movie from.
– Twenty years. Twenty. Years. Don’t you
think he would have shown up by now?
– [Zac] No, obviously not.
After classes get out that afternoon,
we see Laurie making a phone call as
the buses are loaded for Yosemite. And
I just realized it’s a BellSouth phone,
same as what Casey Becker uses in Scream.
She’s talking to a woman named Mrs. Cheney.
– Mrs. Chaney, can I call you right back?
– The name Chaney is usually eponymous in
the horror genre, because of Lon Chaney,
probably the most iconic silent horror movie
actor of all time. Chaney was known for his
portrayal of an array of monsters, which
is most fitting for this Halloween movie,
where the central theme is so focused on
Laurie going back to kill her monster.
Unfortunately, Mr. Brennan nearly
shoots an innocent man in the process.
He got a little too jumpy when the security
guard Ronnie came up to check on them.
Actually, if we go back and slow down that scene,
it actually is Michael approaching in that first
shot, but when we cut back after Brennan fires
the gun, it’s now Ronnie. At first it seems kind
of like the movie is trying to cheat the audience,
but when you think back, it actually is consistent
with how hallucinations are handled earlier in the
film. There are instances where Laurie has visions
of Michael, and has to close her eyes for a moment
to realize it’s actually someone else. Steve Miner
made the choice to show us what the characters
think they see, rather than showing the objective
truth, and I think this is a good tactic to make
the audience feel like they’re more in the moment.
This is also not the first time or
last time someone has been mistaken
for The Boogeyman. Ben Tramer got
killed for wearing the mask in 2,
– RIP Ben Tramer
– [Zac] Ted Hollister got shot in 4…
(sad music),
Spitz was killed by Michael Myers
after dressing up as him in five…
(more sad music)
Freddy Harris nearly got beat
down in Resurrection, … we
don’t really care about that one… and
Mr. Tivoli got angry-mobbed in Kills.
– That one was just weird.
– As much as I love H20’s story, and how
it does something different with the Halloween
formula, it’s hard to get past the fact that
Michael Myers just doesn’t look very scary
in it. A lot of this goes back to the mask.
I could try to talk about this, but I know
someone who studies the Michael Myers masks like
his life depends on it. Here’s Jimmy Champane.
– This movie has a very similar problem
to Halloween 4 where I like the vast majority of
the characters, the kills, the setting, and pretty much everything about it is cool, but there's one glaring issue that
holding it back and that is the mask. Or in this
case, masks. By our count Halloween H20 uses 3
real masks and one CGI monstrosity. None of them
are what I would call good but some are better
than others. Either way, Michael’s overall look
in this movie is a mess. To me at least.
– [Zac] Outside of the mask, there are
a couple of other moments that took away
from the horror. I love when Laurie walks
through the corridor looking for Michael,
but then we turn back and see him just lowering
himself down with one arm. I like how they’ve
added a new move to his repertoire, but
like… where was he when Laurie walked by?
There’s not that much space right here.
I need to see this whole maneuver.
And then when she’s hiding under the
tables. I don’t get why he can’t just
bend down to see where she's hiding. I
know that wouldn’t be as suspenseful,
but it doesn’t make sense that
he doesn’t think to do this.
Ultimately, this allows Laurie to
stab him with the California flag,
which is probably symbolic of something but I
don’t really know, and later, drive him off a
cliff and chop his head off, finally putting an
end to her 20 year war with Michael Myers. Or so
we thought. Because Michael Myers cannot
die as long as you have $20 in your pocket.
Next up on Things You Missed: a Resurrection
would soon be upon us. Someone kill me.
– Even I cannot defend Resurrection.
– [Zac] Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for
new horrors every week, ring the deathbell and
select all notifications. I will… I suppose… see
you in the next one. Assuming we both survive.
(spooky dance music)